is this where your idea
of uh training with lower belts yeah
quite a bit comes from
yeah i've actually just as a side
comment and maybe you can elaborate
i the the place the gym uh
balance studios with uh phil and rick
mcglurry's where i got my black belt
where i grew up as a jiu jitsu person in
philadelphia
they have a huge number of black belts
but they have a huge number of
all other ranks and the way they
picked sparring partners people you
train with
is very ad hoc it's very loose it's very
one of those places
one of those gyms where you can just
kind of you can train for like three
four hours
and it's great you could take a break or
you could jump back
in very informal yeah and you can go to
war with black belts but then you can
also
play around with the purple and the blue
belts and so on excellent
and that was really beneficial for
growth and you know you can pick which
because everybody has a style and you
can pick which style you really want to
work on right
and then i came to um
boston broadway jiu jitsu with
john clark who i love he's a good friend
but you know
the it's a little bit more formal and i
found myself this very interesting
journey
i i would be training with black belts
the whole time
and uh it was a very different
experience
i found myself exploring much less i
found myself
um learning much less i mean part of
that is on my
on me but part of it was also
realizing that uh wow there's a value to
training with people that are much worse
than you yes
is there is there a philosophy you could
speak to on that yeah um
you probably know it already um you know
from your studies and artificial
intelligence that
all human beings are naturally
risk-averse this is a
bias which is deeply seated in in all of
us
um i'm sure you're you're well read on
people like taversky and etc
who talk about this all the time for
your viewers
uh there are numerous psychological
experiments that have shown that most
people
to the point of irrationality fear loss
more than they are excited at the
prospect of an equivalent gain
so for example if you have a hundred
dollars in your wallet
you're more worried about the idea of
losing the hundred dollars that you have
now
then you would be excited by the
prospect of gaining a hundred dollars
that i could potentially offer you um
this comes out whenever you get black
belt versus black belt confrontations or
any kind of
similar skill level whenever you get
similar skill levels
the chances of defeat get very very high
interestingly if you're a white belt and
you're going against a black belt you'll
take risk
why because there's no shame in losing
to a black belt when you're a white belt
so you'll
you'll play more light-heartedly and
you'll you'll have a more fun role
but when you have very similar skill
levels
you're going to come back to what the
techniques
that are most likely to get you a win
that number of techniques is usually
pretty small
and if you're always battling with the
same tough opponents
every day where if you make even a
single error
it will cost you that match in sparring
and you don't like losing
you're going to stay with a very small
set of moves
you might get slightly better at their
execution over time
but you as an individual will not grow
growth
as it does in organic life forms
comes from small beginnings and builds
over time
you can't take an untested untried move
and get on a world champion black belt
it's going to get crushed
so it's not ready for that it's like a a
lion cub
being thrown out into the serengeti
plains the lion cub
is just too small and too ineffective
it's a lion
but it's a cub and it's not until it
grows into maturity that it can be a
line that can dominate the serengeti
planes
that's why i always encourage my
students to play with a variety of belt
types
and spend the majority of their time
with lesser belts for development
purposes when you're getting closer to a
competition you obviously want to change
that you want to be getting
more a competitive sense of of hard work
but you must learn to divide up your
training cycles
into non-competition cycles
where you're presumably working with
people who are
slightly lower in leveling yourself and
in some cases quite a bit lower than
yourself
and then competition cycles where you're
working with people much closer to your
own skill level
you